madame monsieur bonsoir voici les
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
samedi 15 mai l'otan assume le
bombardement du village de korytza au
sud du kosovo mais ne s'explique pas
comment des civils ont pu être tués à
bruxelles on parle de cibles militaires
légitimes à belgrade en revanche toulon
annonce 87 morts
on y voit la preuve du caractère
génocidaire de l'agression de l'otan en
corse les nationalistes unifiée
réunissent leur réussissent leur
démonstration ils étaient plusieurs
milliers dans les rues d'ajaccio pour
appeler à la reconstruction de la nation
corse en russie boris elle s'il sort
vainqueur de son bras de fer avec les
communistes de la douma il ne s'est pas
trouvé suffisamment de voix pour engager
contre lui la procédure de destitution
et puis nous irons à cannes pour la
représentation en compétition du dernier
film de pedro almodovar tout sur ma mère
un film particulièrement bien accueilli
par la critique
l'otan ne parle pas de bavure ni
d'erreurs après le bombardement du
village de korytza au kosovo qui aurait
fait 87 morts et 78 blessés selon les
serbes
il s'agissait bien selon l'otan d'une
cible militaire et d'un poste de
commandement sans pour autant expliquer
la présence de civils albanais à bonn on
parle de boucliers humains mais pour
belgrade c'est au contraire un exemple
éclatant je cite du caractère
génocidaire de l'agression de l'otan
françois corner c'est une fille dit
cette femme
elle n'a plus le maire elle n'a plus de
père je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
pourquoi on est là pour quoi
quelle explication donner à cette jeune
femme et à ses autres survivants du
bombardement de koriche à terré depuis
deux jours dans leur douleur après la
mort de 87 des leurs erreurs bavure
boucliers humains
quelle justification avancée face à
l'horreur qui frappe une fois de plus
c'est persécutés du nettoyage ethnique
au kosovo
c'est des gens qui ont été cachés dans
les collines ou dans la campagne et qui
ont été d'après les indications que nous
avons et des témoignages des survivants
ont été amenés sur ce site par des
policiers serbes juste l'après-midi
avant d' attaque en question l'otan
répète aujourd'hui catégoriquement ces
massacres de civils et affirment que le
village de cory champ situé à 5 km de
prizren sur la route dessous varecka
abritait une position militaire
retrancher un poste de commandement
incluant de l'équipement comme des
véhicules blindés de transport de
troupes et une dizaine de pièces
d'artillerie corrige ça consisterait
donc selon l'otan une cible militaire
légitime répertoriés sur la liste des
cibles à frapper et non un objectif de
dernière minute improvisé reste à savoir
comment les serbes auraient eu vent des
prévisions de frappes de l'alliance dans
cette région de prizren mais une chose
est sûre l'invitation machiavélique des
serbes aux réfugiés kosovars
qu'habituellement il persécute avait un
but précis provoqué par méprise de
nouvelles victimes civiles pour
discréditer l'otan et tous la relayer
rapidement par la télévision serbe
ce qui fut jusqu'à l'alliance et le
pentagone ont senti le vent du boulet et
refuse d'être accusé une nouvelle bavure
à washington est tout seul on multiplie
aujourd'hui les conférences de presse à
ce sujet question dans leur cockpit les
pilotes des chasseurs bombardiers de
l'otan pouvait il se rendre compte que
l'objectif midi
hard core i chat était ceinturé par un
bouclier humain réponse non voilà ce que
les pilotes ont vu sur les écrans de
leurs radars d'acquisition avant de
tirer leurs bombes ou missiles guidés
laser images diffusées ce soir par le
pentagone
des engins tirés d'une altitude d'au
moins 5000 m pour éviter les tirs
d'essai à et une distance pouvant aller
de quelques dizaines à quelques
centaines de kilomètres le bombardement
de cory jane ne pourrait donc dans ces
conditions être qualifié de bavure il
n'empêche que la guerre électronique
acer ses qualités notamment pour la
sécurité des pilotes mais aussi ses
défauts
de son côté la russie a fait savoir
qu'elle pourrait revoir sa position sur
le conflit au kosovo si les
bombardements n'était pas stoppée dans
les jours qui viennent
et puis l'otan a continué ses frappes
aujourd'hui contre des dépôts de
carburant et des ponts l'un de ses
avions auraient peut être été abattu
près de belgrade c'est en tout cas ce
qu'affirment les serbes alors en duplex
du siège de l'otan à bruxelles jean marc
qui louent jan margot soir est ce que
cette information est confirmée à propos
de l'avion et puis d'une façon plus
générale comment l'otan explique-t-elle
la mort de victimes civiles à korytza
vient pour ce qui concerne l'avion vient
ni confirmation ni démenti tout
simplement on attend on procède à des
vérifications
alors pour ce qui concerne la voir les
civils à korytza je dois dire qu'il ya
un certain flou qui subsistent l'otan le
prononce ni le mot bavure ni le mot
boucliers humains en quelque sorte
elle réfute le terme bavure mais sans
pour autant accuser explicitement les
forces serbes d'avoir recouru à la ruse
à la tactique de boucliers humains à
leur première raison c'est que la ferme
bombardé était bien l'objectif
identifier visé est vérifié par les
forces de l'otan selon le temps il
abritait dont vous le savez des éléments
d'artillerie qui pilonnaient
régulièrement les visages kosovars les
villages kosovars alentours
deuxième élément à défaut d'apporter des
explications sur ces morts civils l'otan
posent une question comment se fait-il
que dans une région comme prizren où des
centaines de milliers de gens ont été
déplacés par la force plus de cent mille
en tout cas des kosovars 400 d'entre eux
au moins ait pu choisir volontairement
de passer la nuit dans une course de
ferme adjacente à un poste de
commandement serbe
donc à une sim et bien ce soir cette
question reste en suspens nous ne sommes
pas sur le terrain nous a dit tout à
l'heure le porte parole de l'otan vous
les journalistes n'être pas sur le
terrain une manière de sous-entendre
vous n'êtes pas sur le terrain pour
vérifier pour restituer la réalité d'un
village qui selon amnesty international
avait déjà été à plusieurs reprises la
cible des forces serbes
merci jean marc et puis on apprend qu'un
énorme nuage noir se déplacent en ce
moment de la serbie vers la bulgarie et
la roumanie à la suite des frappes
effectuées par l'otan sur le port de
prades chauveau et sur la mine de bord
parmi les cibles de l'otan aujourd'hui
le sud du kosovo à la frontière avec
l'albanie des bombardements tout à fait
perceptible côté albanais à coup caisse
comme ont pu le constater
valérie fournioux et guillaume fêtera le
poste frontière de maureen à ce matin
comme depuis deux jours les serbes ne
laisse passer que très peu de kosovars
postés le long de la frontière ils
continuent de renforcer leurs positions
quand vers 11 heures des avions de
l'otan ont commencé à bombarder la ville
de zhouqu une ville située à dix
kilomètres d'ici sur la route qui mène à
prizren l'axé principal qui relie le
kosovo à l'albanie
les frappes ont duré jusqu'à 16h30
puis vers 17 heures un groupe de
quatorze hommes et d'arrivée des hommes
épuisés qu'ils nous disent n'avoir ni
mangé ni bu depuis trois jaunes depuis
qu'il était aux mains des forces serbes
maltraité et séparés de leur famille
il témoigne
on nous a encerclés
on s'est rendus et conduit h team nous
étions trente mille personnes regroupées
par les paramilitaires les serbes n'ont
voies séparées de nos fans et depuis
mercredi on n'a pas de nouvelles ils
nous ont dit toi à toi toi ils nous ont
traités comme des sauvages
ils nous ont emmenés au commissariat de
police
acheminer la police nous a frappés comme
des barbares
ils m'ont dit tu es un terroriste de
l'ue ces cas et ils m'ont battu la
policière nous disait tu as lutté contre
nous et c'est pour ça qu'on te frappe
ils nous ont même demandé de chanter des
chansons slave et techniques
nationalistes serbes dans le couloir
d'autres étaient battus c'était pour
couvrir leurs cris et c'était chacun son
tour soit d'être battus soit de chanter
des hommes choqué meurtri qui nous ont
confié avoir témoigné pour que les
nations unies l'otan sache qu'il reste
près de 30 me kosovars regroupés à ch'ti
main par les forces paramilitaires faire
et puis toujours à propos des réfugiés
le hcr estime maintenant à près de 800
mille le nombre des réfugiés qui ont
franchi la frontière depuis le début des
bombardements sans compter ceux qui
étaient déjà partis avant en macédoine
300 nouveaux réfugiés ont pu arriver
aujourd'hui
mais il arrive que des serbes quittent
eux aussi le kosovo on les retrouve
alors en serbie bien sûr mais aussi au
monténégro où ils rejoignent ceux déjà
chassé lors des guerres précédentes en
exclu au milieu gauche la vie en croatie
ou en bosnie et leurs témoignages vous
allez l'entendre sont totalement
différents anne consigny et dida
c'est une distribution de vivres une de
plus mais cette fois les réfugiés sont
serbes
certains viennent de bosnie ou de
croatie chassés par les précédents de
guerre de l'ex-yougoslavie il ya
quelques années
d'autres arrivent tout juste du kosovo
vesna monténégrin en accueille chez elle
j'en ai 11 ils sont arrivés le 1er avril
et le 1er mai ils sont tous plus ou
moins de la famille il y a d'abord une
jeune femme de des chats ni avec ses
quatre enfants
son mari est resté aux côtés vous
fonctionnaires il est assigné à son
poste de travail
selon son épouse les bombardements sont
cités les pions que même les serbes
souhaiterait partie quand les bombes
sont tombées il y a eu des blessés pas
de mort mais c'était terrible j'ai
décidé de faire ma valise tout seul j'ai
pu partir avec la voiture du voisin
j'avais peur de prendre le bus les
autres c'est pareil sinon ils seraient
pris aux nombreux risma héberge sur
quatre personnes chez sa mère à la
campagne mal engagé dans l'action
humanitaire la jeune femme est prête
elle et tous les kosovars albanais et
serbes mais stimule mois sans doute de
l'exagération parce que racontent les
albanais difficile pour vesna de prendre
autant de recul par rapport à ce que lui
raconte sa famille serbe du kosovo
les rapports sont vraiment très mauvais
dans la ville de mitrovica est partout
au kosovo on ne se sent pas en sécurité
à cause des bombardements aériens par
n'y a pas de logique
franchement je ne sais pas si les
albanais sont chassés de leurs villages
s'ils le sont c'est sans doute parce que
ce sont des gens qui sont de look shekau
qui auraient dès l'été ronnie est alors
seul à vendre des pannes qu'on pouvait
leur emploi
les sna aimerait être neutres comme son
gouvernement
les monténégrins ne peuvent pas non plus
rester indifférent aux récits des serbes
kosovars avec les combinaisons souvent
des liens samedi
il est il alors des incertitudes sur la
réalité de la déportation imposé par les
serbes et albanais ou encore sur les
exactions commises par les serbes
c'est ce qu'a cru pouvoir dire
l'écrivain régis debray retour d'un
voyage de quatre jours au kosovo ce
qu'il a pu écrire alors dans le monde a
provoqué un tollé aussi bien des
intellectuels que des journalistes ou
des responsables des chemins de terre ce
soir régis debray accepte de revenir sur
ses propos qui vous allez entendre ont
un peu évolué marcel trillât et daniel
levy un homme qui n'hésite pas à semer
la tempête au retour d'un voyage de
quelques jours en macédoine en serbie et
au kosovo
régis debray publié une lettre au
président de la république dans le monde
daté du 13 mai il y exprimait sa crainte
que la france ne fasse trop scouts en
participant aux frappes de l'otan contre
la yougoslavie et certaines de ses
affirmations
au fait scandale autocrate fraudeurs
manipulateur et populiste monsieur
milosevic n'en a pas moins été élu à
trois reprises il respecte la
constitution yougoslave pack parti
unique pas de prisonniers politiques
on peut le critiquer sans se cacher
les pires exactions ont été commises les
trois premiers jours avec incendies
pillages et meurtres
plusieurs milliers d'albanais ont alors
reçu l'ordre de partir
pas de trace depuis d'un crime contre
l'humanité dans la presse aussitôt c'est
un véritable tollé des réactions
violentes accusant régis debray de
servir la propagande de milosevic
d'autres plus mesurés comme ce matin
dans libération celle de rony brauman
les récits des réfugiés ont recoupé
vérifier démontre à l'envi que il s'agit
d'un programme et non pas d'un programme
de terreur et d'expulsion et non pas de
quelques exactions dont seraient
coupables des bandes paramilitaires et
cela évidemment cela ne se voit pas ça
ne peut pas observer slaughter cela ça
s'étudie dans un contexte politique et
pas dans une sorte d' observation comme
ça vite fait en l'espace de deux jours
et c'est ce que régis debray n'a pas
voulu voir et c'est ça qui me choque
sur le terrain les nombreux témoignages
recueillis par nos correspondants semble
bien confirmé la persistance des mason
dans le village d'origine étaient quinze
ans que je sais par terre les mains
comme ça ils étaient tous en inde amma
soit ils ont tué les hommes
ils ont tué les hommes les femmes et les
enfants
ils les ont éloignés les hommes ils les
ont tués
jean tuer massacrer crever les yeux des
enfants
il y a trois jours j'ai vu 50 cadavres
alignés dans les champs cinquante
personnes je vous dis il y en avait
plein dans les fossés éparpillés au bord
de la route
interrogé hier soir régis debray
regrette certaines allégations non
vérifiés mais il persiste à faire
entendre sa différence
qui n'a pas envie d'être côté des
réfugiés j'ai passé six jours aux côtés
des réfugiés puis après je me suis dit
mais attendez c'est tellement horrible
tout ça il faut aller voir de l'autre
côté ils commencent comment est ce
possible
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'étais de
l'autre côté japon sera même quelques
impressions quelque chose vu comme moi
je n'approuve pas les serbes je ne suis
pas pro serbe et je ne suis pas anti
cernes
je suis pour que se rétablisse au plus
vite une situation de justice une
situation de paix voir par exemple
lorsque vous dites qu'il ya eu des
exactions ont les trois premiers jours
derniers au bar n'est pas dit non non
non je suis dit que c'est lui d'après ce
que j'ai pu reconstituer en recoupant
encore une fois les les témoignages des
gens qui étaient là bas ce sont les
trois premiers jours qui ont été les
plus atroces mais bien sûr qu'ensuite il
y a eu des déportations bien sûr qu
ensuite il ya eu des exactions qui peut
nier quand vous arrivez là bas vous
voyez des villages brûlés vous voyez des
magasins albanais saccagé les vitres
brisées c'est poignant
vous avez l'impression car pogroms est
passée par là cet affreux et les marques
les marques de du nettoyage si j'ose
dire
elles sont omniprésents si on devait
stationner des troupes aux frontières du
kosovo est intervenu ponctuellement là
où il y avait nettoyage but qui tel ou
tel village avec un mandat des nations
unies ingérence humanitaire mais
localisés là où les choses se passent je
pense que
moi j'aurais été d'accord avec une
solution comme cela que je ne comprends
pas c'est comment on peut faire une
jarre de punition collective pour les
serbes pour tous les serbes
régis devrait affirme avoir voulu
surtout provoqué un débat sur la
stratégie de l'otan'' au kosovo et sur
ses conséquences
objectif atteint en corse maintenant les
nationalistes ont réussi leur
démonstration d'unité pas moins de
quatorze organisation d'appeler à la
même manifestation cet après midi à
ajaccio un événement quand on sait à
quel point ces mêmes organisations ont
par le passé étaient divisés il faut
dire que l' incendie d'une paillote sur
une plage et l'incarcération du préfet
de corse sont passés par là michèle
fines et grégoire rosina sous un soleil
de plomb
des milliers de manifestants il y a deux
ans encore
ils s'entre déchiraient aujourd'hui à
l'appel de 14 associations nationalistes
ils défilent d'ensemble sur le pavé
d'ajaccio
c'est à dire tout le monde est là
survivants tout le monde est là on est
là mais marc françois sont tenus
l'ancien leader de la consulte il ne
défilera pas mais sa présence est
symbolique dans cette manifestation
c'est un premier pas vers la
consommation nationale et ce même si on
en croit une union de façade
toujours été là on a toujours été aux
manifs est lent comme tout le monde et
la belle et la bête
l'abbé mondoloni et le curé nationaliste
de lille à ses côtés pierre poggioli
l'un des anciens chefs du fln s'ils
croient que la population de l'île était
sous l'étouffoir depuis 13 mois
une profitant de l'assassinât du préfet
erignac état français a apporté la
preuve qu'il comprenait encore moins
qu'avant le problème corse est bon il
s'est enferré dans une situation se
contentant de dire que la population a
été avec sa politique
et puis les événements qui ont su qui se
sont succédé avec à l'arrivée la sphère
de la paillote ont montré que c'était
pas du tout ça est que le peuple corse
aspire à autre
la manifestation se termine sur la
grande place d'ajaccio par un discours
plutôt musclé prédisons que l'actuelle
république française va s'effondrer
comme ceux qui vont dans le mur de
berlin
deux réunions en manifestations
publiques
le nouveau comité a bien l'intention
aujourd'hui d'organiser l'avenir du
mouvement nationaliste sur l'île
alors michel fine vous avez suivi cette
manifestation qu'est ce qu'il faut en
retenir pour l'ensemble de l'île est ce
que la question de l'autonomie par
exemple est de nouveau d'actualité
alors ce qu'il faut savoir d'abord c'est
que ce mouvement celui que celui qu'on a
vu se dérouler aujourd'hui c'est un
mouvement qui ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
qui ne date pas d'hier qui ne date
surtout pas de la dernière crise que
vient de traverser la corse crises liées
à la sphère des paillotes c'est un
mouvement qui est né en février dernier
sur la plaine orientale de l'île et ce
n'est pas un hasard parce que la plaine
orientale de l'île est le lieu où se
sont déroulées la majorité des
interpellations dans le cadre de l
enquête sur l'assassinât du préfet
erignac c'est donc un mouvement qui
s'est créée en opposition la politique
d'état de droit en opposition également
à la politique menée en corse par le
préfet bonnet et dans cette perspective
le rpt lors des élections territoriales
les nationalistes la seule liste
nationaliste en présence a obtenu 17%
des voix ce qui est énorme le politique
a bien compris tout ça il a essayé de
récupérer ou de relayer ce mouvement
depuis quelques jours effectivement en
entend le président de l'assemblée de
corse josé rossi dire dire pourquoi
pourquoi pas un nouveau statut pour la
corse pourquoi pas un statut d'autonomie
pour la corse effectivement aujourd'hui
on en reparle parce que j'ose dire aussi
c'est que le mot d'autonomie plaît
beaucoup aux nationalistes il semble que
sa proposition soit la traduction de
l'intérêt bien compris d'un homme
politique qui compte en corse mais qui
sait aussi qu'il devra lui compter de
plus en plus sur les voix nationalistes
merci michel sachez que la famille du
passager décédé sur le vol paris dakar
après avoir reçu une piqûre de
tranquillisants va porter plainte même
si on sait maintenant qu'il s'agissait
d'une personne dépressive sa famille
veut savoir dans quelles circonstances
cette piqûre lui a été administrée
qu'elle entre en ont été les
conséquences
c'est un demi succès ou un demi échec
comme on veut la première écolo parade
des verts à paris n'étaient que quelques
milliers cet après midi à se promener
entre la bastille et le carrousel du
louvre mais pour les ordinateurs qui
conçoivent ce rendez vous plus comme une
fête que comme une manifestation il faut
laisser du temps au temps comme on dit
la gay pride à ses débuts du style
n'avait pas rassemblé beaucoup plus de
monde la crue du rhin les choses
semblent se calmer un peu aujourd'hui
même si on a eu peur la nuit dernière du
côté de lauterbourg où une usine
chimique du type seveso été menacé par
la rupture d'une digue
en revanche la situation reste difficile
en suisse dans le canton de berne
frédéric dupuy une usine chimique à haut
risque à quelques mètres le rhin en crue
autrement dit à lauterbourg en alsace la
vague de pollution a été évitée de
justesse toute la nuit devant l'ot
menaçante pompiers et gendarmes ont
tenté de construire un rempart protéger
l'entreprise sacs de sable dick de
gravier aujourd'hui tout danger est
écarté dans la région même si ce n'est
pas encore visible
le gros de la crue est passé mais le
débit de l'eau reste important et le
dispositif de surveillance maintenu de
peur qu'une digue ne cèdent ne plus dur
est passé nous l'espérons du côté de la
suisse le niveau est en train de baisser
mais je pense qu'on en a encore au moins
pour deux jours même si la décrue est
annoncée en suisse le loup est toujours
omniprésente dans certaines régions
l'art un sou influent du rhin a envahi
le canton de berne
dans la ville même l'eau atteint par
endroit un mètre de haut l'aéroport
noyer a dû être fermée plus au nord en
allemagne à la ville d'esch bailleur a
observé localement le plus haut niveau
jamais atteint par leur 1,8 m 53 les
villes de karlsruhe et mannheim ont été
touchés mais là les habitants sont
restés au sec
hp ailleurs le rhin devrait continuer de
monter dans les prochaines heures
mais la ville de 30000 habitants
devraient être épargnés en russie le
coup de force annoncé les communistes à
la douma n'a pas eu lieu il espérait se
venger de boris eltsine qui n'a cessé de
les combattre depuis son arrivée au
pouvoir
mais ils n'ont pas réussi à recueillir
suffisamment de voix pour engager contre
lui la fameuse procédure de destitution
gilles rabin et franck brisset il était
contre ils ont gagné
il a manqué 17 voix sur 440 et une pour
que passe à la douma la procédure en
destitution de boris eltsine il pensait
faire de ce 15 mai le dernier du siècle
le jour de la grande revanche rouge
il n'arrive pas à croire qu'ils ont péri
dehors ils ne savent toujours pas et y
croit encore il veut vraiment seulement
obtenir la destitution de yacine mais
aussi revenir sur l'histoire de ces dix
dernières années et effaçait la
disparition l'union soviétique n'a
perdre de sa puissance de son empire de
son angle il condamne en bloc l'otan
l'occident et les juifs
la libéralisation sexuelle et la vente
des terres pendant le dépouillement le
chef des communistes guennadi ziouganov
était venu gonfler le moral de ses
troupes
jusqu'au bout il a cru à sa victoire la
proclamation des résultats du vote est
sans appel
même le troisième chef d'accusation
celui qui devait passer à coup sûr la
guerre en tchétchénie n'a pas obtenu la
majorité des deux tiers
on ne peut pas considérer que les
résultats sont bons il faut recommencer
demain recommencera pas demain
l'histoire donne rarement rendez-vous
deux fois de suite
on viole le droit des députés après
l'annoncé des résultats
soulagement devant la douma de ceux qui
manifestaient pour la roue de l'histoire
on ne peut pas la faire tourner en
arrière et la roue de l'histoire ne
tournent pas vite en russie et le camp
des vainqueurs réside à laisser passer
la provocation délibérée d'un député
communiste les élections en israël
scrutin a lieu lundi pour renouveler les
membres de la knesset élire le nouveau
premier ministre
mais curieusement alors que ce scrutin
s'avère essentiel pour l'avenir du
processus de paix la question des
territoires n'a quasiment pas été évoqué
pendant la campagne pourtant les
implantations elles se sont poursuivies
vingt nouvelles colonies juives ont
ainsi été installés ces derniers temps
en cisjordanie reportage à coraf jacob
de maryse burgot cette nouvelle route
peut sembler banale elle ne l'est
pourtant pas elles mêmes stratégique
ménard aime boire y est à l'origine des
travaux de construction financés par
l'état d'israël
des millions de dollars investis par
l'état hébreu alors que nous sommes en
cisjordanie dans ce qui pourrait être un
jour l'étape
quand on devait passer par des villes et
des villages palestiniens on était sans
cesse soumis à des tirs de pierres des
cocktails molotov ou même pire des
tyrans automatique
il fallait impérativement que l'on
puisse en construire ces routes de
contournement de façon pour accéder aux
villes nos villages en toute sécurité
ces routes permettent aussi de relier
les 160 colonies juives de cisjordanie
et elle morcelle chaque jour un peu plus
le futur pays de yasser arafat
nous sommes encore à viacom 1300 colons
jusqu'ici et dans les nouvelles
constructions qu'on en attend 40 plus
haut les mains série sont là depuis 9
mois à milan les cadres supérieurs
ils ont tout quitté pour venir vivre
dans ces préfabriqués protégé du
voisinage arabe par des barrières de
sécurité pour que ces terres restent
suis à jamais une prétendante juifs qui
vit qui étudient cabaye qui cultivent la
terre aussi qui construit des écoles des
bâtiments
je commence à vraiment quelque chose de
très important et pour le fait que ce
soit un père juif je n'ai pas de doute
ça fait la paire que qui évoquaient de
nature à la torah c'est ici qu'ont
l'étude le rabbin de thibaut dirige
l'école talmudique de la colonie lui et
ses étudiants voteront à droite lundi
prochain car c'est cool armé en
permanence seront remerciés benyamin
netanyahu d'avoir tout tenté pour
retarder un accord définitif de paix
avec l'autorité palestinienne
notre peuple habiter cette terre il ya
des milliers et des milliers d'années
n'ont jamais quitté son attachement pour
cette terre pendant tout son exil
aujourd'hui que ce retour est devenu
réalité et les prophéties se sont se
sont matérialisés ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui nous allons perdre notre
lien avec
avec ses terres et ne fait que se
renforcer durant jeu l'homme qui gagnera
les prochaines élections aura une lourde
charge celle de faire la paix alors que
les palestiniens et la communauté
internationale considère l'extension de
ses colonies comme un obstacle majeur en
france la carte vitale a bien du mal à
décoller cette carte électronique qui
doit remplacer les vieilles carte de
sécu est pour l'instant peu prisé des
praticiens puisque environ 3000 médecins
libéraux seulement sur les 110 milite
contre la france est bien utilisé cette
fameuse carte les caisses d'assurances
veulent donc les motiver en leur
attribuant à partir de juillet une aide
financière mais ça ne suffit pas
beaucoup de médecins recule devant
l'importance de l'investissement
matériel les explications de françoise
valais et de jean louis goût serre
vous êtes ma patience camille
numéro 6 dans les salons les foires
partout où elle peut la sécu explique à
quoi va donc servir ces petites cartes
vertes que tout le monde a reçu ce n'est
pas une carte de crédit ni un carnet de
santé mais un moyen de communiquer avec
la caisse d'assurance maladie dû patient
le kiné la servir le radiologue du
laboratoire
quand tout le monde sera équipé tout le
monde pourra remplir les feuilles de
soin électroniques et donc les envoyer
directement la sécurité sociale à la
solide plus de feuilles de soins remplir
plus de timbres à coller et en quatre
jours le maladie rembourse parce que je
compte de cette carte c'est que depuis
un certain temps on est équipés d'écrans
et d'ordinateurs partout et à la
sécurité sociale ou du jury des
paperasses mais si des patients sont
prêts les médecins prennent riscle en
ile-de-france région où les cartes ont
été distribuées en dernier une
cinquantaine de praticiens seulement
sont équipés
je trouve que la formation est très très
très légère et ça veut dire donc
forcément que nous en plus d'un de
boulot un cadeau déjà lourd de 13 12 à
13 heures par jour plus la formation en
dehors dire genre 21h minuit il faut en
plus qu'on aille se former sur
l'informatique
d'autres sont moins réticents et pour
cause
quel matériel acheté comment le faire
fonctionner à bayonne c'est la caisse
d'assurance maladie qui aident les
médecins
depuis deux ans qu'il est équipé le
docteur bernard a toujours la même
interlocutrice
sophie se déplace là un gros problème
aussi vous avez vu en a mis pour une
minute trente deux minutes peut-être et
sans être à l'as du clavier on fait tout
avec la souris honnêtement non c'est
tellement plus simple
de retour à la caisse sophie s'occupe
personnellement des dossiers des
patients transmis par le docteur bernard
ici les feuilles papier diminue de jour
en jour au profit de la transmission
internet la capitale ça marche
la totalité les officines de pharmacie
sound system 76% miser sur et utiliser
la carte vitale et plus de 200 médecins
ont déjà basculé en ce procès dans les
caisses de bayonne à miser sur
l'information des médecins
un exemple les professionnels du
thermalisme se mobilisent contre le plan
de maîtrise des dépenses de santé
proposée par la cnam selon ce plan ne
seraient plus remboursés les soins des
rhumatismes ce qui représente 60% de
l'activité les cures dans le languedoc
roussillon à balaruc les bains où se
sont rendus karine comazzi et françoise
mazou ce projet met en péril la
troisième station thermale de france
avec les bains de boue argileuse de
l'étang de thau martin soigne depuis
trois ans arthrose et ostéoporose trois
semaines de soins à balaruc lui coûte
3000 francs remboursés à 65% par la
sécurité sociale
le reste par sa mutuelle c'est cette
cure n'était pas remboursée
est ce que vous voyez là faire non je ne
pourrais pas la faire par contre ce qui
me restera à faire c'est un magicien
départ c'est à dire passer par des
docteurs pour balaruc les bains c'est la
douche froide comme martin 35 mille
curistes en majorité des retraités à
petits revenus viennent ici chaque année
soigner leurs rhumatismes des soins que
la caisse d'assurance-maladie envisage
de ne plus rembourser ce serait une
faillite quasi instantanée pour
l'établissement thermal et pour le
canton de balaruc-les-bains combien
d'employés
450 salariés donc 300 agents terme aux
saisonniers qui donc sont là pour
appliquer les soins et donc
nous serions obligés de mettre au
chômage 90% à peu près de l'effectif il
y a deux ans la mairie vivement incités
par la caisse d'assurance maladie a
investi 25 millions de francs pour la
rénovation des termes traumatisés par la
perte des emplois industriels
balaruc et ses 5700 habitants ne vivent
que des curistes et de leurs familles au
total cinquante mille personnes qui
séjournent trois semaines par an si le
gouvernement a avalisé pathogène de la
cnam
ça serait les disparitions de cette
activité et de la microéconomie cas
qu'elle génère l'e commerce la
restauration le tourisme etc
vous apportez du village était moi je
parle que palais qui rythment ce sur une
ville qui serait hissé artistes se
réveiller en attendant balaruc fait le
plein déjà 35 mille curistes ont réservé
pour cette année rembourser les eaux ne
sont pas prête de se tarir
c'est qu'ils ont maintenant avec le
départ du tour d'italie le giro qui a eu
lieu ce midi en sicile un tour sous
surveillance tous les coureurs ont dû se
soumettre à un test de dépistage aux
pages et deux d'entre eux ont d'ores et
déjà été exclu christelle bertrand et
mathieu dreujou richard virenque a
retrouvé sa tenue de cycliste
ce matin au départ de la première étape
du tour d'italie le transfert en france
m
mais le dopage est déjà présent premier
communiqué première annonce de cas
positifs
hématocrite en plus de relative des
moyens qui est prévue demain entre 6h30
et 9 heures du matin tous les coureurs
engagés ont été contrôlés les résultats
ne se sont pas fait attendre
deux d'entre eux ont un taux
d'hématocrite supérieur à la limite
fixée à 50
l'union cycliste internationale avait
prévenu un test sanguin aura lieu avant
le départ des trois grands tours dans
toutes les équipes en général et chez
polti en particulier pour ne refuse pas
de s'exprimer
mais la consigne est claire on ne parle
que de vélo nous
le peloton a subi cette première étape
le climat lourd du contrôle du matin et
la chaleur sur le parcours peut arriver
les coureurs plus tard que prévu
richard virenque termine avec les autres
dans de telles conditions
une reprise c'est jamais facile pour ma
part on assume une mouvement
je pense que tous les courants journée
ans ou par la chaleur
comment vous sentez pour les prochaines
étapes
je pourrais comme améliorer les coureurs
ont encore vingt-et-une étapes à boucler
plus une
les contrôles inopinés promis par l'ue
c'est un mot de football youri djorkaeff
quitte l'inter de milan c'est officiel
il explique sa décision par la récente
démission du président de l'inter avec
lequel il était très lié
mais chacun sait aussi que youri
djorkaeff été reléguée depuis quelques
temps sur le banc des remplaçants et
qu'il n'avait pas vraiment trouvé ses
marques à l'inter de milan même s'il ya
gagné une belle coupe d'europe les
quarts de finale du championnat de
france de rugby que vous avez pu suivre
sur france 2 et la leçon imposé par
toulouse au stade français 51 à 19,2
n'est guère un stade rouge et noir
rempli de 40000 spectateurs des joueurs
complets à bloc
al'approche du coup d'envoi et un
premier ministre venu en voisin de
cintegabelle assurément ce toulouse
stade français bien plus d'un quart de
finale c'est la fiche de l'année une
affiche que les toulousains en blanc ont
dominé de bout en bout
il mène déjà par 7 à 0 quand michel
marfaing le trois quarts centre file
vers l'en but parisien pour le deuxième
essai du match
mais les bleu et blanc champion de
france en titre réel en trois minutes
ils inscrivent deux essais par byers et
dominici c'est finale avant la lettre
tient toutes ses promesses
des promesses mais aussi des cadeaux
comme celui offert par richard du fign
delta mac qui n'en demandait pas tant à
la pause les toulousains mènent déjà par
28 à 12 retour des vestiaires ntamack
encore lui slalom dans le camp adverse à
lui tout seul il transperce la défense
parisienne pour aller marquer son
deuxième essai personnel
le stade toulousain battu l'an dernier
par les joueurs de la capitale tient sa
revanche en fin de match cédric déborde
inscrit un 7e et dernier essai pour
toulouse
score final 51 à 19 le stade français
n'aura fait illusion
et oui tu étais le temps l'ambiance
blanc et
les toulousains quant à eux peuvent
continuer à rêver en démissionner ils
affronteront beaubois bourgoin qui l'a
donc emporté 14 à 8 face à
bègles-bordeaux dans l'autre quart de
finale et puis un autre tennis avec la
qualification de julie halard pour la
finale du tournoi de berlin
elle y retrouvera la suissesse martina
hingis le festival de cannes avec ce
soir le nouveau film de pedro almodovar
tout sur ma mère
curieusement c'est la première fois que
pedro almodovar fait partie de la
sélection officielle
les fans du cinéaste espagnol n'ont pas
été déçus le délire dans les couleurs
les situations et les dialogues est
toujours aussi présent même si ces
dialogues sont parfois un peu cru en
tout cas le public a été séduit pascal
deschamps et bruno livertout voilà un
homme qui sait parler aux femmes sans
doute parce que nul ne parle des femmes
comme lui il faut dire que pedro
almodovar a offert à ses quatre actrices
des rôles limites
l'une joue un travesti qu une autre une
actrice homosexuels la troisième une
religieuse qui tombe enceinte la
dernière une infirmière qui perd son
fils de 17 ans les situations extrêmes
et un scénario sur le fil du rasoir pour
ce film avec lequel pedro almodovar
voulait rendre un subtil hommage aux
femmes
l'amoureuse oui c'est un film dédié aux
femmes où mr aux femmes qui aimeraient
être mère ne le sont pas alors aux
hommes qui aimerait être des femmes et
aux actrices qui jouent des rôles
d'actrice
d'une manière générale je crois qu'il
est dédié tout le genre féminin nous
postons la comptable au yukon a fini
aussi qu il fait comme à la ville et le
communiqué car elle ne savait toujours
c'est tellement fort l'histoire qu'il
faut le faire avec absolument avec
naturalité total avec un simply city
total avec ana hina
comment dire une fragilité aussi total
mais avec ni gran courage
estampillée cinéaste de la transgression
almodovar manier aujourd'hui plus
qu'hier l'émotion autant que l'humour
mais son discours n'a pas changé nous
sommes des êtres multiples il faut nous
accepté comme tel par les footeux la
tête d'audel camions et mais c'est tout
le temps loquace almodovar regarde les
femmes avec un regard de femme
il comprend exactement ce que nous
ressentons car ils acceptent de la part
féminine qui est en lui ok en fait la
maman depuis drôle mode voire ne veut
toujours pas aller voir les films de son
fils dommage car contrairement ce que le
titre laisse supposer tout sur ma mère
ne dévoile aucune indiscrétion sur sa
vie privée tout à fait autre chose
maintenant avec le film de steven
soderbergh
l'auteur de sexe mensonges et vidéo qui
avait d'ailleurs obtenu la palme d'or en
89 cette fois il revient hors
compétition avec un polar l'anglais est
un acteur mythique theron stampe nicole
cornu langlois et jean louis malle un
tiercé gagnant
ils ont tous été primés à cannes peter
fonda pour easy rider terrain ce timbre
meilleur acteur pour le cd skis valse
des repères pour sexe mensonges et vidéo
c'est donc avec émotion qu'il revienne
dans ce festival pour lie mais l'anglais
l'histoire d'une vengeance impitoyable
wilson sort de prison et veut tuer les
responsables de la mort de sa fille ils
pensent que valentine est le coupable
le choix de peter fonda et de terrance
simple est l'une des clés du film duel
entre eux et intérêts aux mêmes
sensibilités y aurait dans des cultures
différentes
l'anglais terrance tympans a toujours
interprété deux types de personnages
anges déchus ou tueurs en série avec les
plus grands réalisateurs comme williams
will leer joseph losey ken loach fellini
david lynch un passé qui imprègne son
rôle de wilson
la prison ou détruit complètement où
vous élève en ce sens wilson est
essentiellement un survivant lie mais
est comme mon mur
dessange et peter fonda selon la méthode
de soderbergh est aussi un mélange de
son passé et du présent
dans ce rôle de valentine's producteurs
de disques amateurs de jeunes femmes un
personnage loin et proche de saisie
rider montagne comme un personnage ancré
dans la réalité
captain america était un mythe un rêve
deux grands acteurs pour un film
imprégné de la nostalgie d'un âge d'or
du cinéma américain dont le moteur était
la liberté deux acteurs heureux de
retrouver à cannes l'énergie la magie du
succès qu'ils ont connu et qu'ils vont
retrouver avec ses films
c'est bientôt la fin de ce journal je
vous en rappelle les principaux titres
l'otan assume le bombardement du village
de gorizia au sud du kosovo mais ne
s'explique pas comment des civils en
plus être tué à bruxelles on parle de
cibles militaires légitimes à belgrade
en revanche soudan annonce 87 morts on y
voit la preuve du caractère génocidaire
de l'agression de l'otan et puis encore
se les nationalistes unifiée réussi leur
démonstration ils étaient plusieurs
milliers dans les rues d'ajaccio pour
appeler à la reconstruction de la nation
corse dans un instant la météo est
patrice drevet à 20h50 le plus grand
cabaret du monde avec patrick sébastien
à 1h20 le journal ce sera plus rance
duprat demain 7h dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac recevra gérard klein à
midi argent public avec sylvain attal
les jeux autres auraient quant à moi à
demain 13h bonne soirée sur france 2